so let's talk about a little bit about
home sales i know you briefly touched up
on it if you don't mind going a little
bit deeper into it
pending home sales hits record high in
august keyword
pending pending home sales the national
association of realtors pending home
sales index serves 8.8
last month on an all-time high of 132.8
signaling the u.s housing market rally
continued into the fall
economists surveyed by bloomberg expect
an increase
of 3.1 what is
happening in real estate well so you
have
a once in a lifetime situation here
right
think about where we were a year ago if
you were hip
if you were a millennial you wanted to
be in the urban center
you wanted to be in a high-rise you you
were wondering why there weren't enough
grocery stores and things to serve you
if you're
living living the life downtown
all of these think about the cranes
throughout america
all what the cranes have been building
big high-rise office buildings big
high-rise apartments
that has been flipped on its head so
i mean and all over my twitter feed are
people leaving california
and moving to prosper and moving
to south lake and that they've
discovered
you know life in texas but but we have a
mass exodus right now i have friends
outside of new york city and in
westchester county
that have been trying to sell their
house for two years and they took it off
the market when they saw how white
hot that house how quickly housing was
heating up is people were leaving new
york city
and they're like i'm taking my house off
the market i'm gonna wait until
prices get where i really want them to
be and they were smart and then they got
the price that they wanted
that is the fundamental driver behind
that is jay powell and his happy
printing press and the federal reserve
buying up
mortgage-backed securities forcing
30-year conventional mortgage rates down
to
record lows so then that then does the
question becomes is it fake or is it
real
is this fake is this fake growth it is
it is not the same growth that you think
that it is because
lenders are you're starting to hear
anecdotes from real estate
agents i got the offer i got the buyer
the seller accepted the bank turned them
down
so lending standards are coming down if
you talk about capital one
synchrony jp morgan credit card lines
are being cut
because remember right now you have 12
months of forbearance
forbearance means that you do not have
to pay your mortgage for 12 months
through march of 2021.
so i mean if you're if you're the lender
you're not happy at all
or if you're a landlord in america
but from the perspective of where
64 of americans think that the economy
is worse today than it was a year ago
you look at the housing market and
you're like the housing market begs to
differ
well that's easy enough when 15 of fha
loans and fha loans are the ones that
you get three and a half percent down
payments
on and that business is blowing up it's
huge it's white hot but 15 of those
loans are delinquent
but the banks can't foreclose so you've
got
buyers buying into a white white white
hot market but a lot of it is being
engineered and
fabricated so i'm a big fan of renting
right so i'm i'm that person that lives
in the center of downtown miami
like i don't even have a car i'm not
looking to move into the suburbs that
was my life in new york
okay so you understand that most of my
friends in new york obviously if you
live in l.a you're driving all over our
pets i went with pat in la we're driving
over every different
different city it's hard to do that in
l.a living in a city center
but if you're living in downtown chicago
downtown boston
downtown miami uh even in dallas over
here
you know i'm a fan of renting so i mean
i actually did an episode where
44 of homeowners regret being a
homeowner and 63 percent of millennials
regret being a homeowner so people are
seeing these super super super low
interest rates
versus what they were 10 20 30 years ago
when interest rates were double digits
and people say of course i need to get
into the housing market of course i need
to refinance
of course i need to do this the tiny box
of what the payment is
that's all they're looking at and you're
saying that it could end ugly
i'm saying that a lot of especially a
lot of
of the first-time home buyers who are
getting into the market they don't
they don't understand that they're that
that home prices have never been this
high in the history of mankind
they don't know that they're buying in
at the top of the market home prices
have
been as high and interest rates have
never been this low correct so what's
the what's the what's that uh
that's the correlation yeah when
interest rates are low home prices are
high we're interested
you're hearing the national association
of realtors say well pricing is becoming
an issue
even with interest rates as low as they
are even with mortgage rates that's a
scary thought that that's the part when
it becomes scary look
you know is you're a bodybuilder when
you no longer are growing
and you're doing every single steroids
and growth hormone in the body
there's a problem there that's why i
know paul schreiner that's what's going
on
that's kind of what's going on today
meaning
you're doing every single thing to get
the economy and real estate going and
it's still
barely hanging on and powell comes out
saying they're going to keep the
interest rates at zero until 2020
forever until 2023 wow it's a scary car
in his press conference he said that
they kept interest rates at zero for
seven years last time and nothing bad
happened
well no nothing bad happened because he
came and printed more so
the i mean look we're talking about
another two trillion dollars of stimulus
but
if again if you're throwing good money
after bad
and you're not getting anything for it
all you're gonna do
is four months from now we're gonna be
talking about the next stimulus package
[Music]
you